welcome to star wars we are in a galaxy
far far away
and here there are the good Jedi like
obi-wan Kenobi or Yoda with this special
way of speaking to you all breathing's
and on the other side are the evil Sith
like the masked man Darth Vader
here we see representations of the good
and dark side of the force an energy
field that holds the galaxies together
and can be controlled for things like
telekinetic tricks in Episode one the
Jedi are still creating order in the
galaxy the evil Trade Federation is
procedure in the planet Naboo will save
Queen Padme Amidala of course I'll just
let myself be elected Supreme Chancellor
no assist comes my master well at least
I picked up the highly gifted Anakin
here
Anakin trained as a Jedi in Episode two
to fall deeply in love with Batman poor
war while the separatists from the Trade
Federation continue to destroy the
Galactic Republic the Serbs are
destroying my Jedi ding-dong did you
order a giant army of clone
stormtroopers oh great now we're
fighting the separatists but in Episode
three
Palpatine shows his true face I am the
fifth Lord
here's disfigured in battle the
sadducees Anakin only the dark side can
save you're pregnant Padme from death
and now we will kill the remaining Jedi
I can't all Jedi are killed except Yoda
and obi-wan Kenobi he dismembers his
disciple Anakin who now only survives
his walking heart-lung machine Darth
Vader Padme gives birth to the twins
Luke and Leia and then dies many years
later in Episode four Palpatine is the
glottic emperor and Darth Vader his
right hand men now we are building the
ultimate weapon of mass destruction the
Death Star but the rebels get hold of
the blueprints princess lair is among
them quick r2d2 and c3po bring the plans
to obi-wan Kenobi
everyone claps the young Luke Skywalker
your father was a Jedi so let's go to
the rebels and the chauffeur's a han
Solo and his buddy Chewbacca
chauffeur I can fly you to the desk
thoughts of blow us up
Luke manages to do that but obi-wan
Kenobi gets killed in episode 5 Luke
wants you to train him to become a Jedi
tell me his Darth Vader my father your
father he is what I must defeat him but
Dad if the better fighter and takes the
sons right hand off No
and Yoda dollies
yeah it's taken as a slave no and Han
Solo is put into a carbon freeze room
the Empire is building a new Death Star
but Luke saves his friends in Episode
six then there's a showdown with his
father bang bang and the Emperor says
come to the dark side
no I'd rather kill you but don't fader
saves Luke and dies the second Death
Star is destroyed again it's happily
ever after but not so fast because
thirty years later in Episode seven
everything is the same the collecting
Empire is now called the first order and
as a new masked man named kylo Ren the
son of lair and Han Solo
this time the dark side well when but
the young scrap metal collector Rey
discovers her Jedi powers and along with
stormtrooper deserter Finn and Han Solo
destroys the new Death Star but now at
least my dad Han Solo dies sure ray
finds the lost Luke Skywalker again and
we are in the current Star Wars saga
right now then what about this offshoot
rogue one it tells us how the rebels
between Episode three and four get to
the Death Star plans without dear fans
this Star Wars made the force be with
you